un peu farceur les nouveaux venus du
centre équestre de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
julie est monitrice d'équitation depuis
deux ans son rôle former les jeunes
cavaliers pour la compétition et surtout
développer la relation avec leur monture
c'est un court avec beaucoup de nouveaux
projets dont des bébés et des tout
jeunes bébés tout juste des bourgs et
c'est pour ça que c'est un petit peu
branlant au départ mais faut les former
ses cavaliers là qui les forment des
trous sur les coins et à des complicités
qui se crée il ya des affinités qui se
créent et on essaie de privilégier ses
affinités là parce que surtout sur du
dressage de jeunes chevaux
c'est le plus important est là vraiment
vraiment besoin comme julie six autres
moniteurs et soigneurs travaille ici
depuis le 28 août sous la structure est
devenue ski équitation et à changer de
gestionnaire la région ile-de-france
reste propriétaire mais c'est la société
privée dahlia qui a repris les rênes
si l'offre du centre reste la même les
modalités elles ont évolué un nouveau
site internet une nouvelle page facebook
et les adhérents ou mêmes extérieur on
possibilité maintenant de pouvoir
s'inscrire en ligne d'effectuer des
règlements en ligne de pouvoir régler
aussi en plusieurs fois
ce qui était quelque chose de beaucoup
plus complexe quand on est géré par par
l'état après 20 ans d'existence le
centre équestre compte aujourd'hui 250
adhérents débutants ou confirmés
cette nouvelle gestion devrait lui
apporter un coup de jeune avec quelques
investissements
une nouvelle carrière et une dizaine de
boxe sont prévues